[MUSIC PLAYING]
STUDENT: Google Classroom
is mission control
for teachers and students.
With Google Classroom, you
can create new courses,
enroll teachers and
students, and have
students submit assignments.
With the launch of
the Classroom API,
you can now seamlessly
integrate your apps
into Google Classroom.
TEACHER: And you'll be
working off your own laptops,
so make sure--
STUDENT: The API provides
a RESTful interface
to help you manage and
provision classes at scale.
TEACHER: So let's get started.
Let's talk about
the Classroom API.
Please come in and sit down.
The Classroom API enables
you to create new courses
and specify a name,
a section, and room.
Each course can be
further described
through the description
heading and description fields.
Each course also has
the state indicating
whether it's provisioned,
archived, actived,
declined, or unspecified.
Now, we know a
lot about courses.
You can't have courses
without teachers and students.
So let's see how
those two differ.
Teachers can create new courses
and manage course enrollments.
Yes.
STUDENT: Students can
list course details
or view the teachers
for that course.
The documentation says
that students and teachers
are identified by unique
ID or email address.
Where do they get those details?
TEACHER: Right.
STUDENT: Oh!
They're returned by
the Google Admin SDK.
TEACHER: Right.
There are several ways to
enroll students and teachers
into a course.
The first is programmatically,
directly through the API.
So here we will enroll teachers
and students into the course.
Yes.
STUDENT: Another way is
to send them an invite.
Now, it says here to
send an invite you merely
need the user ID of
the teacher or student,
the course ID of
the intended course,
and the role for that user.
Then you can accept or
reject these invitations
using the Classroom API.
TEACHER: Right.
STUDENT: So we've
done enrollments.
What about assignments?
TEACHER: Good question.
The Classroom Share button
makes it easy for your users
to submit files.
You as developers simply have
to drop the button on your page,
include the necessary
JavaScript resources,
and then add a target URL.
[BELL RINGS]
TEACHER: Once you've done
this the rest of the process
is taken care of for you-- yeah.
The Classroom API lets
you integrate your apps
with Google Classroom.
You can create courses,
enroll teachers and students,
and have students
submit assignments.
I hope you've been paying close
attention in this DevByte,
because there will be an exam
in a couple of weeks' time.
Slow down!
STUDENT: But if you haven't
been paying close attention,
don't worry about it.
Because the documentation and
samples at this link will get
you started quickly.
Who said you can't cram at the
last minute and be successful?
[MUSIC PLAYING]